tom is with us in Indianapolis hey Tom
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you tom pleasure to be here good thanks
I call certainly how can I help sir
well basically I am I'm married I've
been married for six years and I'm
concerned that my wife may have some
kind of a spending addiction
and I'm really looking for I know
absolutely nothing about addiction or
very little so I wanted to see if there
was any type of advice you could give
some spice someone potentially dealing
with a spending addiction and if you
knew of any good books or authors that I
could read to really educate myself and
become a help me properly support my my
wife and yet not enable okay it's
probably a different track than I would
take if you called and I mean I probably
wouldn't follow that path and you
wouldn't either if you said she had a
drug addiction or an alcohol addiction
when you push something past misuse into
the addiction definition then you need
to involve professional counselors
immediately so if that's truly what it
is if it's not just simple immaturity
run amok and no boundaries and no one's
ever told her no and she's just a
princess that's different than addiction
right addiction is I'm out of control
about two percent of the public are
obsessive compulsive spenders they have
they've had a complete breakdown and
there is an addiction to it that is very
very real it's not you know everybody
used to make fun remember a decade or
two ago Imelda Marcos with all their
shoes right and that kind of stuff and
uh but but you know and so are you
seeing extreme patterns like she's
coming on buying things she didn't
realize she bought um no it I wouldn't
say she didn't realize that they were
purchases that were hidden from me that
I don't find out about until later um
and then when I confront her about it
she feels bad I mean it
and it causes you know it destroys the
snowball what not destroy success - yeah
absolutely
heat shaming that makes you mad yeah it
does ago with a lot of anger and she'll
get better for a little bit and then go
back and do it again and it's just a
kind of a cycle of ending the way I
answer questions on this show tom is
what I would do if I were in your shoes
okay and I don't think I would try to
read a book to fix this and I don't
think I'd visit a website to fix this if
I were in your shoes I would seek out
some professional marriage counseling
and I would start it there and then in
the first marriage counseling session I
would bring this up so that that
counselor who should be a trained
professional by the way and I'm a person
of faith so I'm always going to look for
a Christian marriage counselor if it's
me because I want that worldview in the
decision-making process that we use here
but different people will feel
differently about that but that's me
okay
so if you're going to do that then you
decide that but but here's the thing if
you're sitting in a marriage counseling
session and you say look we've got a
real trust breakdown there's integrity
breakdown I get completely angry she
gets completely shamed and guilty
regretful doesn't do it for a while but
then goes back to hiding and deceiving
and lying to me about these purchases I
don't know do you think mr. counselor
maybe she has a spending addiction and
let the marriage counselor ferreted out
and and depending on what type of
counselor you got ahold of and so forth
they may be qualified to actually work
with her on that but I would open the
door through marriage counseling and let
somebody that's a pro look at the
symptoms in detail not some goober on
the radio like me all right because I
know I'm no more counselor than fly the
moon man I'm just a guy okay I mean I do
I do counsel people I do give them you
know direction on things but I'm not
trained in that area I have had the
benefit as a financial coach or
financial counsellor of seeing a lot of
addiction over the years and um and and
I will tell you there's actually a 12
step program called debtors anonymous
and a lot of the people that are in that
12-step program are struggling with
actual spending addictions they're very
real it is a real spending addiction but
I've also talked to a lot of people that
they didn't have a spending addiction
they just had simple self control
problems and that's a different there's
a difference to that it's a maturity
thing it's a selfishness thing it's a
control thing and all those kinds of
things and those are things fall under
the heading of growing up emotionally
and spiritually and a good marriage
counselor can lead her and you through
either one of these tracks depending on
what is determined whether this is
actually an addiction but an addiction
is way over on the end of the spectrum
and it's going to take pretty extreme
types of input not just a little bit of
change of information in other words
Financial Peace University won't help
you if you've got an addiction so it's a
waste of time because always can do
aggravate you and make her feel bad but
but if she's just immature and and just
doesn't have good self-control and needs
a system that the two of you work
together on then Financial Peace
University will work for the two of you
and I'll give you that I have you been
through the class uh we're in week seven
right now yes very I'm very appreciative
of those thoughts we're trying to get on
the same page has she entered into the
whole budget process with you um yes
she's in the process and that's that's
where it kind of manifested itself as
more than just to me at least as
improper spending because it she would
agree to the budget and then later on it
would so during the seven weeks she's
agreed to a budget and then goes out and
spins otherwise yes and doesn't think
that's wrong uh when confronted she does
but but then it's like okay so how how
do we fix this stuff how do we stay on
stay on track okay yeah I'm going to go
back to I'm going to go back to my
original suggestion and you guys need to
see a pro yeah are you in a good Church
uh yeah it believes so okay ask your
pastor pastor for ramen Dacian of a good
Christian marriage counselor all right
and that's somebody that's licensed
that's been trained okay yep they can
they can look at you guys and go okay
this has got all of these symptoms and
these are the breakdowns and then
because it sounds like that there is
something broken because she's sitting
across the budgeting table from you
making a promise and then a week later
breaks that promise
that's an integrity breakdown added such
a deep level that you may be that it you
may be facing what you're afraid of
so yeah you guys need some help that's
what it comes down to and it's beyond
Financial Peace University it's beyond
Dave Ramsey on a radio call and I'm glad
you're singing and I'm glad you're
loving your wife well and you walk with
her through helping her find what's
broken and and with God's help create
some healing very cool this is the Dave
Ramsey show